ça laisse alors stop
oui mais c'est moi alors les amis je
profite de ce petit moment d'accalmie
pour vous proposer un deal à deux
secondes à tanger explique le deal si
vous gardez la couche vierge jusqu'au
soir vierge
attention c'est ressens rien dedans il y
aura une belle récompense
ah ok je réponds si sipa kaka jusqu'au
dos de ce soir je donne pas un jeu donne
pas deux donnent trois chocolats trois
chocolats et 6 voilà ainsi qu'à cas avec
moi ça va marcher comme ça je vous le
dis oui parce que c'est hors de question
que je passe mes journées à changer des
couches à la vie des des slips toi ça va
quoi tu vois je moi je suis pas là pour
ça voilà par gaspard tu as le droit de
faire caca bah oui je leur écrasent bien
tout parce qu'il mange tellement
seulement mais ils mangent que du riz
oui c'est super bon pour la constipation
du coup plus d'odeur et tu change tout
les couches c'est pas con alors juste
aventure parce que lorsqu'il de la
compote de pruneaux comme ça le soir il
a touché leur part mme mais c'est pas
dangereux
bon ben j'ai eu plus d'idées sur un
forum ça arrive
je savais que les cris des bébés ces
étudiants xpress que dupuy ce panel et
ses voleurs de fin tellement ça arrange
pas qu'on la nature à agent vient faire
là je la prends des lingettes pour vous
essuyez voilà peux-tu les enfants mais
ils dorment quand même parfois non
jamais heureusement parce qu'il ya des
techniques pour endormir les bêtes us
alès et somnifère j'ai pensé aussi mais
pas du tout pour les sortir faut qu'il
se dépense beaucoup en maine et au parc
le parc
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu attends je rends
service à constance toiture en service
on j'ai besoin de thunes passe gens
prient la boutique ouais ouais ouais
mais franchement ça m'a assez cool c'est
ouais c'était devenu routinier et ont
selon ce tract tout de suite la télé 2
j'ai besoin de projets tu vois tu ne
veux je sais pas de aller de l'avant de
renault va me demander en mariage quoi
ai-je bien oui je comprends pas pourquoi
je comprends pas pourquoi le vin qui te
dit à l'avant ce qui va te demande en
mariage c'est complètement con il se
trouve que j'ai découvert une bague dans
sa veste
bah ouais mais c'est peut-être pas pour
toi intime et rsa pour toutes que j'en
sais rien sa maîtresse peut-être pas
c'est un problème assez de ces deux
problèmes et je ne sais pas ce qu'il est
fidèle mais tous les mecs sont pas comme
moi tu devrais te méfier il a demandé à
une copine de l'aider à choisir la bac 5
bassins cet automne sommet trust rate
rien tu fais chier même temps c'est vrai
après tout tu ça tape peut-être dans ton
dos je tiens à marier alors on passe à
30 pour le dimanche tu peux pas tu peux
pas être vous et ce mec ce mec il est
chiant sein des sciences
c'est en examinant plus tard bonjour je
me présente
je m'appelle adrien adrien valette
[Musique]
ces mauvais bagnas j'adore je suis
diplômé et j'ai lu tous les bouquins de
françoise dolto 1
pour ceux qui connaissent je sais pas si
vous connaissez le jeu très bien tout le
monde je ne bougerai de mon bureau sans
aucun prétexte
hors de question de lever le petit doigt
pour l'aider parce que ce gros con là a
décidé de me pourrir la vie que je veux
venir sauver celle de vos enfants
je savais la vigne à vos risques et
périls
bon merci merci de ton attention mode
alors vous avez déjà fait la
connaissance de mode c'est ma future ex
femme qui a des petits soucis
qu'est ce que c'est que de vivre avec un
ado attardé pendant dix ans
un jour peut-être je sais pas ce que
j'aurais envie de fonder une famille et
on fait pas un enfant avec un enfant
un vrai mec c'est un mec un boulot un
minimum d'ambition
du coup on fait pas l'amour
bon j'ai décidé de monter une crèche à
domicile bon c'est sympa et tes
conneries mais j'ai du boulot manqué
pour pas laisser votre enfant ici ces
décrets chiffon 8h21 raconte pas les
rues vous avez une heure passe vraiment
très bien fait d'arrêter d'être un petit
grandissent c'est mon frère mais y
connais rien en éducation phare été
arrêté à et démerdez vous j'espère que
vous aimez ça le maillot parce que vous
allez en manger tous les jours
oh [ __ ]
termine ce soir là pourquoi parce que
sinon je balance la vidéo du bébé qui a
failli tomber à tous tes clients si tu
fais ça moi je balance sur internet le
film qu'on a fait l'été dernier en
espagne le rafting non le fucking paquin
va pas tarder et des techniques pour
endormir les deux vêtues crs se diffère
pas du tout pour les sortir faut qu'ils
se dépensent emmène les au parc voulait
toujours pas faire la sieste quand tu es
à cauet
qu'est ce qu'un type comme toi peut
apprendre à des mioches
ça
pas si mature que ça tombe à 15
[Musique]
tallulah signifie que brailler et le
petit là bas c'est quand justin bieber
allait pour la mèche
[Musique]